in our exclusive interview two of the
grand jurors in the briana taylor case
are describing what happened
during the jury's proceedings taylor as
you know was shot and killed in her home
during a police raid in march
no officers have been charged for her
death and the kentucky attorney general
says that their actions were justified
jurors number one and number two told us
they were only presented with wanton
endangerment charges in the case of one
officer who fired into a neighboring
apartment
they say that they were shocked that
more serious charges were not presented
by the attorney general's office they're
speaking out now
so everyone understands the truth the
case was
at least for me was pretty mentally
exhausting
and upsetting what did you think after
it became
the story that it became and people
started marching in the streets
i was hurting i was upset i wasn't
sleeping
my first thought was brianna's mom
i felt that she needed to know the truth
i was of the same mindset
i need her to know
that it wasn't us i can tell you're very
emotional
number one talking about it it's where
is that emotion
coming from it's hurt i mean i i have no
idea how she feels
i can only imagine but i needed her to
know that
again to to what number two was saying
that
is that that we'd tried
we were only allowed to decide on what
they they gave to us
is it hard for either of you to speak
out now because you're going to open up
a whole nother door in a whole nother
level of conversation
yes and no i mean
doing the right thing is hard i'm way
out of my comfort zone right now
grand jurors one and two tell us that
prosecutors did not give them the option
to deliberate over manslaughter or
murder charges in the case of brianna
taylor's death
their lawyer says that kentucky attorney
general daniel cameron
misrepresented their findings to the
public when it's all over
and the attorney general takes his
position
and speaks to the press and the public
and put it all on the grand jury
instead of owning up to whatever
decisions were made from that office
it's clear they were blindsided by
attorney general cameron's decision
i agree they were blindsided daniel
cameron at his press conference
described brianna taylor's death as a
tragedy but not a crime
what do you say to that no i believe
that there are some crime involved
you know the whole procedure the way
they got the warrant
um it was a hodgepodge team that went in
there and they had no coordination
can i ask you what you both think of the
police uh behavior and actions that
night
negligent negligent they couldn't even
provide a risk assessment and it sounded
like they hadn't done one
so their organization leading up to this
was lacking that's what i mean by they
were negligent
and in in the operation number two
they were criminal leading up to this
and everything that they the way they
moved forward on it
including the warrant uh was deception
what do you hope will come out of
speaking out today number one
this is all about truth and
accountability and
being forthright my biggest thing was to
make sure
that brianna's mom knew that the city of
louisville and jefferson county
there are good people in that city and
in that county
and they stood up and they tried to do
the right thing
and when grand juror number one reached
out to you what did he say to you
specifically
and what was your reaction when you
heard what he had to say what i got out
of it was
the services a grand juror was over and
the service as a citizen of kentucky had
started
and there was a desire to make that
record clear
and to give clarity to the entire public
you feel strongly about it both of you
you're number one and you're number two
yet you've decided you don't want your
identity shown why
mainly for my family's
safety there's people out there that
don't agree with what we're doing
most people do but there's a few out
there that
that probably don't and i just soon
keep it that way do you happen to know
or can you say if other jurors feel this
way
the way the two of you feel it isn't
that i can say
definitively about other jurors but i
felt
that the uproar at the end of it i would
think that yes
i don't think we're alone in this later
this morning former louisville officer
brett hankinson is scheduled to be in
court for a pre-trial hearing on wanton
endangerment charges that he's facing
we did want you to know again that we
reached out to kentucky attorney general
that's daniel cameron and he did not
give us a new statement
but last month he did tell a local fox
affiliate quote
if the jurors wanted to make an
assessment about different charges
they could have done that you know both
of these men spent a lot of time you
know they looked
at uh the the evidence i'm always amazed
guys at how seriously people take this
process
both of them yeah took this as a very it
mattered to them
and they wanted to get it right and they
want people to know this was not their
decision you could tell when they talked
about briana taylor's mother yes they
talked about her they were thinking
about you know the family involved
and what this would mean to them they're
trying to clarify the record and that's
important
is there something more that could
happen legally if it turns out that the
jurors were not given proper
instructions
well it's interesting the fbi is of
course is still investigating this case
and they both would like to see a
special prosecutor
assigned to it but attorney general
daniel cameron is the one who'd
appointed he's the one who makes a
decision about a special prosecutor
so they weren't very hopeful about that
tony but they would like to see
something happen in this case that's
called the system yes
yes it is